if you don't think we got enough lists
during the year in this BuzzFeed world
that we live in well the years about and
then that's where we really double down
on the list so we've got a list of the
most googled terms in 2014 uh all right
so we're gonna hit a couple of these so
Robin Williams was the most googled term
in 2014 so what surprised me about that
just real quick is that you know that
was just an instance that have you know
it happened one day obviously a minute
it was the burst for a week it's a shock
but it wasn't something that was going
on all year so I thought that even
though it was shocking of course that
the net sort of usage of that term I'm
surprised that was the number one thing
a World Cup number two that was
obviously huge for you know the two
months or so that it was going on Ebola
the malaysia airlines i want to talk a
bit more about that the ALS ice bucket
challenge flappy bird I never know when
flappy bird is a nap i didn't even
download it i fought the power I'd never
have played library and I fought harder
than you do conchita wurst which we did
a little research on will tell you about
that in a second Isis obviously it's no
surprise frozen was one of the big
movies of the year and the socially so
these were the top 10 most search terms
I have to apologize again look I keep
clearing my throat because I have such
bad post nasal drip so I'm really sorry
that was that was actually number 11 was
post nasal drip number you know when you
put Kathy labman into Google like those
kind of post-nasal drip complete it
comes up now that I can't follow him so
is there anything on that little be that
surprised you in any way it seemed it
basically sort of somewhat yeah Robin
Williams is the number one term is
surprising absolutely and sad yeah and I
think that if you do look at all of the
things that are sort of in the top 10
list it is a really good snapshot of
sort of what we thought about what we
were really pre-conceived that's that's
right what we were we roast consider
earlier we were preoccupied with ya
during the year last year I'm curious
the other thing about what your guys is
top Google searches was for me it was of
course and eerie spire because haha what
I'm saying how many times would you
repeat Google anything other than
yourself right so I don't know how you
know usually my googling involves well
my my partner by Beyonce now I could say
he cooks a lot so a lot of times he
yells things at a kitchen a measurement
thing so I google measure
it's all right that's my that's my
bright or just not you know little
factoid yeah I don't think I think I'm
good I google constantly and I love it
and I can't believe that it hasn't been
around my whole life but I don't think
there's anything that I google
predominantly do you guys think that
there's less stuff in your brains now
because of this like you don't have to
store yeah you don't have to keep
information i remember when i was a kid
like playing Trivial Pursuit with my
family and my uncles especially my uncle
and my dad were so amazing it remember
every little fact about World War two in
the day that this happened and that
happened and I feel like nobody of the
next generation probably starting with
Gen X don't remember things in that way
because we can just go to the well but
see bound back to my head back to me
being like a physics experiment as I
mentioned last time but the things that
I don't need to keep in my brain Garrett
I get rid of phone numbers don't
remember those much anymore yeah um but
it gets filled with other stuff my
friend is to have it have a theory that
your brain is like a bucket and you can
only fit as much into it as you can yeah
if you leave room in the bucket then
more stuff will come into it so so I
don't remember certain things that are
so easily accessible yeah I have a good
friend who's a actuary which is most
exciting yeah applications said we
always joke that my brain is like a
warehouse but like a bomb went off and
there's a ton of stuff but it takes a
while to get to and his brain is like a
really small organized closet you can
there's not a lot in there but you can
get to a pretty high so yeah great guy
great guy don't you have to have to have
to be sort of like labels that you like
why you can't remember a person's name
you have to kind of develop a system
like this person I remember his name is
Bill because he has that baseball cap or
some size you know something and I don't
do that enough demonic you like your
vitamin thank you but there are certain
people that whose names i just cannot so
wait so the Robin Williams thing yeah
what I I think that's particularly
interesting as I said is that because it
just it was this burst and that it still
became the number one so what does that
say about us like when we all share this
like in this case a pretty horrific
thing what is that sinama know yeah I
don't want to hear well I mean I think
what you're saying is absolutely correct
though it's like and I did a couple of
papers about this back in college where
the ability to access a lot of different
things all at once sort of has created a
divergent pattern for like our cultural
experiences so it's like because there
are so many different kinds of artists
that you can listen to from a music
perspective like you don't have to have
a room where everybody knows who what
you know what's going on so when these
moments happen these mash finale style
moments yeah you know we're like
everybody goes to the bathroom of the
commercial breaks I like the water table
lowers right because they're also
involved in the show those kinds of
things when they happen well it's
unfortunate that you know he passed away
of course it's it is sort of special
that like all of us for like a moment
are to sort of even if we are googling
doing the same thing it's like it's like
because we're all we were in such an
isolated society that we all kind of
converged like this in a very yeah
modern way yeah but I also think that
what what that says is that you know to
a lot of people Robin Williams was an
incredible source of joy yeah and for
him to die in that way I'm was so rocked
so many people's worlds i think that's
interesting so you think maybe even if
he had died in another way let's say it
had just been a car accident that it
wouldn't have got the traction so really
I so I do he took you know two people
who don't get the personality of the
comic yeah which is a lot of people um
the fact that he took his own life and
and and was suffered from depression we
are heated other two people he was he
was like a savior he was like he was the
light and he didn't have the light yeah
I think that was a really tragic moment
for peace absolutely all right so the
last one that I want to touch on real
quick the Malaysian plane yeah we
everyone talked about it for that month
CNN did like two months of wall-to-wall
endless speculation which was always
preface by saying we're not going to
speculate what happened and then they'd
speculate for two hours we never found
the plane which i think is kind
interesting so they force this stuff
down our throats it's who the hell knows
what happened it's a pretty sick story
actually if you if you really think
about it that we never found this plane
but so we were forced fed it by the
media for that amount of time it never
resolved itself and now we
ever talked about right right so what
does that say about we how we use jazz
on to the next thing that's being forced
down our throats yeah you've watched CNN
for the past four weeks it's all been
protesting but police violence please
find it's like yeah non-stop they'll do
a breaking news alert at the top of
every hour and it'll be literally the
exact same thing over and over and over
again and I think that you know CNN's
model and especially like with all the
other sort of local or not local but
national news organizations to sort of
like just think that like they can get
behind a thing that just going to get
them traction and just push it until
it's dead dead dead been dead might work
for casual viewers for people like cost
you know who watch a lot maybe it's
right now it's really horrible